THE STORM MAKING IT SO MUCH
WORSE FOR SO MANY AMERICANS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GLAD YOU GET TO STAY INSIDE.
>>> WE'RE GOING TO GO OUTSIDE
NOW TO CNN'S PAOLO SANDOVAL LIVE
IN BUFFALO, NEW YORK.
I MEAN, WOW.
WHITEOUT CONDITIONS WHERE YOU
ARE.
WHAT'S IT LIKE?
>> Reporter: KRISTIN, OUR
VIEWERS CAN GOOGLE IMAGE BUFFALO
AND WINTER AND THEY'LL PROBABLY
FIND THIS IMAGE.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW FOR SO MANY RESIDENTS.
I'M ABOUT 40 YARDS AWAY FROM THE
CAMERA, AND I WALKED OVER HERE
TO SHOW YOU, DEMONSTRATE WHAT
THE BIGGEST CONCERN IS FOR
AUTHORITIES RIGHT NOW WHICH IS
LOW VISIBILITY FOR THOSE WHO
DECIDE TO TRY TO BRAVE THE
STREETS IN AND AROUND THE CITY
OF BUFFALO.
I'M GOING TO SLOWLY WALK TOWARD
OUR COLLEAGUE BEHIND THE CAMERA
HERE.
AS WE ARE IN A RELATIVELY SAFE
PLACE TO SHOW YOU THIS, SINCE
THERE IS LITTLE TO NO TRAFFIC.
FOR HOURS -- I'VE COUNTED
PERHAPS THREE VEHICLES THAT HAVE
PASSED BY HERE.
IT'S CERTAINLY TELLING THAT
PEOPLE ARE HEEDING THE WARNINGS
FROM ERIE COUNTY OFFICIALS WITH
A DRIVING BAN THAT'S IN PLACE
HERE.
BASICALLY RECOMMENDING THAT ONLY
ESSENTIAL TRAFFIC DUE TO
EMERGENCIES BE HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU, I'VE COVERED
HURRICANES, COVERED TROPICAL
STORMS, COVERED WINTER STORMS.
IT SEEMS THAT THESE TWO ARE
INTERSECTING HERE TODAY IN
BUFFALO.
THESE ARE CONDITIONS THAT ARE
GOING TO CONTINUE INTO TONIGHT
AND POTENTIALLY INTO TOMORROW.
WE HAVE THAT LAKE-EFFECT SNOW.
LOOK, THERE IS NOT A MASSIVE
SNOWMAKER, BELIEVE IT OR NOT.
IT'S THE WINDS THAT ARE WHIPPING
AROUND, ALL -- THE SNOW THAT HAS
FALLEN AND ADDING TO THAT, THAT
FLASH FREEZING THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO SEE THROUGHOUT THE
NIGHT AS TEMPERATURES CONTINUE
TO PLUMMET, KRISTIN.
BACK TO YOU.
>> PAOLO, THAT WAS INCREDIBLE.
I WAS NOT EXPECTING THAT AT ALL.
I DID NOT KNOW THAT YOU WERE
GOING TO BE IN THE SHOT.
I COULDN'T SEE YOU AT ALL, AND
YOU JUST CAME WALKING OUT OF
THAT BLIZZARD.
IT REALLY DOES SHOW YOU HOW LOW
THE VISIBILITY CONDITIONS ARE
WHERE YOU ARE.
ARE YOU SEEING ANYBODY OUT ON
THE ROADS RIGHT NOW?
OR ARE YOU THE ONLY ONE?
>> Reporter: NO, I'M THE ONLY
ONE.
THAT'S THE ONLY REASON WE FELT
SAFE AND CONFIDENT ENOUGH TO
WALK DOWN THE STREET BECAUSE IF
A CAR WERE TO COME UP, IT WOULD
BE DIFFICULT TO SEE IT OR FOR
THEM TO SEE US.
WE'RE KEEPING A CLOSE EYE ON
BOTH STREETS HERE.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU, WE HAVE
SEEN, LIKE I SAID, PERHAPS THREE
VEHICLES IN THE LAST HOUR OR SO.
WE'VE SEEN SOME LOCAL OFFICIALS
OBVIOUSLY ON PATROL.
ASIDE FROM, IT SEEMS THAT PEOPLE
ARE CERTAINLY GETTING THE
MESSAGE TO STAY HOME.
IT'S NOT JUST FOR THE NEXT FEW
HOURS BUT POTENTIALLY INTO
TOMORROW.
REAL QUICK, POWER OUTAGES IS A
BIG ISSUE RIGHT NOW HERE IN ERIE
COUNTY, NEW YORK.
IN FACT, TWO WARMING CENTERS
THAT WERE SET UP BY AUTHORITIES
EVEN LOST POWER BECAUSE OF THESE
HIGH WINDS AND WITH IT THE RISK
OF DOWNED POWER LINES.
THEY ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
RELOCATING FOLKS WHO ARE WARMING
UP IN THOSE WARMING CENTERS TO
OTHER LOCATIONS.
BUT ASIDE FROM THAT, COUNTY
OPERATIONS HERE, THEY'RE
BASICALLY FROZEN, NO PUN
INTENDED, UNTIL THE CONDITIONS
CAN GET BETTER AND UNTIL UTILITY
CREWS IS GET BACK OUT THERE.
THEY'VE RECORDED WIND GUSTS OF
CLOSE TO 80 MILES PER HOUR IN
BUFFALO EARLIER TODAY.
CERTAINLY YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
GET CREWS IN THOSE CONDITIONS.
THEY WANT TO WAIT FOR THINGS TO
CALM DOWN WHICH MAY NOT HAPPEN
UNTIL TOMORROW EVENING, NIGHT,
MAYBE ON SUNDAY, ON CHRISTMAS
MORNING.
>> I'D SAY I WISH YOU COULD GET
TO ONE OF THOSE WARMING CENTERS,
BUT I KN